who all do you got on this album U I got
Rick Ross I got uh Rob 49 shout out to
Rob great guy I told a lot of people
about ride before he popped
off uh
treated I got um Kevin Gates Gat yeah
hey B rou legend yeah face have you hung
out with him yet yeah he's a very uh
interesting person he's interesed man
but he in in the best way possible I
feel like he's so like spiritually
awoken now you just be hanging out with
him and he just just he just got energy
pouring out of him you know what I'm
saying I like to catch his shows that I
can just to get CU his shows have a good
energy his live shows are crazy homie's
jumping around and I feel like he's just
doing burpees his whole set that
[__] in so he he's he's like
ripped now and [__] yeah yeah we're
doing a show with him I got a drive to
Phoenix tonight cuz uh the station I'm
on out there is like it's like our big
radio show and he's headlined so I'm
looking forward to his set shout out to
Kevin Gates I think I seen that fly I
got I got a couple more people on that
right yeah it's it's it's a pretty
random show but it's Kevin Gates Tech 9
young nudy yeah yeah nudy and Jord
Lucas I did seen it I've seen it uh give
me the dynamic between Rob 49's
obviously from uh New Orleans from New
Orleans obviously Baton Rouge and New
Orleans I feel like historically The
Vibes have been different musically cuz
I there two different worlds two
different worlds two different places
I've never I've only driven through
Baton Rouge never hung out I've hung out
in New Orleans a couple times um what is
the relationship between the two places
today and you know I think it's dope to
see you guys working together but like I
feel like there should be more like you
know pollination of the of everybody
kind of rocking with each other you know
what I'm
saying so Louisiana is a real crab crab
in a bu bucket type of place so um Baton
Rouge New Orleans we always like had
weird relationships rival kind of like
the Bay La yeah it's like it's like not
a serious rivalry but right it's a
rivalry though you know say B La have a
rivalry it's like when it Katrina
happened in New Orleans came to Baton
Rouge and people living out like
everybody was fighting killing each
other all type of stuff you feel me it's
just two different worlds um uh I think
New Orleans is more
uh has a more variety of cultures that
uh influence them uh just but that's
because it's it's it's been a port right
it's a bigger city yeah you feel me it's
[__] football team it's a trade City
you feel me so you always have people
coming in coming out and and influencing
them you know what I'm saying that's why
they have more cultural stuff than us
you feel me that's fair um I thought
what I thought was dope was like they
second line we on second
line interesting yeah you feel me like
it's just different stuff like yeah I I
need to go hang out with Baton Rouge uh
it really ain't nothing in Bat Rouge I
heard the I heard the food's good though
I was going to say the food yeah I was
invited to do like uh is it crawfish
season crawfish ball no there's um
somebody had told me to go out there
with them uh there's like a season in
which you like can hunt crawfish out
there or like they're out and you just
grab like raw crawfish everywhere yeah
you could do that in a random
Pond yeah see my thing is I don't like
crawfish like that I like the meat but I
don't like the [__] be sucking
the heads off and [__] pause big pause
big super back to back pause amazing I
mean do you like
crawfish yeah absolutely yeah yeah I
don't know man they're very like like
you said they're in ponds like yeah like
you can go grab a like certain time of
the year you can go grab uh a crawfish
out of
ditch this is true